[Music]
okay we just got done seeing one called
El Chicano yes which is a basically the
superhero movie about a guy named Diego
Hernandez who is a ex-military LAPD cop
Mexican American guy who during the
investigation of his dead brother who
was an ex-con he runs into some weird
information they found that that his
little brother when he got out of prison
was some kind of a vigilante I don't
want to steal it movies Thunder but
eventually he ends up taking the mantle
of this vigilante and tries to stop a
Mexican invasion a Mexican invasion of
narco terrorists into the United States
like a big yes big and like take over
that area take over the whole era area
and he considers it kind of like an
invading army
he's got it's a pretty cool synthesis
the characters a good synthesis of like
American stuff mixed with like Aztec
stuff he's got obsidian blades he damn
near he doesn't quite cut people's
hearts out
but yeah so you just stabs him I got a
bunch of guns armored outfits you know
kind of like a Batman cross between
banishing the Punisher II I would very
much like the punished very much yeah
that's what I would say yeah I was
watching it like the Punisher but you
know the soundtrack was really kind of
like Batman Begins II very much like
Batman Begins in fact the movie is you
could tell they're kind of trying to
establish this character yeah because
they definitely left it yeah I heard
they left it where they left this is
almost like his origins like the origin
story that's really the only thing I
could knock this movie for is that there
are times where especially like in the
second act it kind of took its time
trying to develop this character and I
think it took
a little bit too much time yeah it's
hard to slow down a little bit actually
was more not so much an action movie
there were like some really good action
sequence yeah but it was more like a
crime drama I'm drama mystery started
off more like a cop movie yeah and like
she was trying to solve this
investigation and some he was going like
investigating so there wasn't like you
know there was gunfights and stuff but
they were kind of feeling far between
like I said yeah it didn't really become
a superhero movie and towards that maybe
like a last 1/3 of it yeah which I guess
that would stand to reason as an origin
story yeah yeah but I just think it took
a little too long for him to finally
become Elsa Colin yeah I can see that
well that's really the only thing I can
I'm gonna dive down the movie I said the
movie is great especially considering
the budget you could tell that this is
actually kind of a lower budget movie
but it was punching above its weight
yeah yeah I honestly I had only seen one
preview of this yeah several weeks ago I
was like alright yeah you know I was I
was thinking even from the trailer I was
thinking oh it's like The Punisher type
of thing yeah but you know set in LA and
you know but I ended up actually liking
it a lot more than I thought I would and
there was a lot more of like a character
study that was expect yeah also I would
like to say those who probably say that
it's a tradition that for a traditional
movie yeah I liked it I liked it didn't
try to do anything tricky it basically
went along kind of along the lines of
what works and yeah in in a hero movie
it didn't try to subvert anything or
flip anything upside down although it
told things in an order which which kind
of kept him wondering and then you find
out oh okay
like like I wasn't sure who the guy was
they never did say he's ex-military they
showed you that yeah while he was shave
and maybe he saw his tattoos yeah but no
one mentioned it but that's what
supported the some of the fighting
skills
did later so you know what I mean he as
he's becoming this vigilante it wasn't a
quick process just based on what I'm
gonna become vigilante there I'm there I
am he had a long history of doing stuff
like a long time breakin for get to that
point
Brooke you know it was kind of him
investigating his brother and then there
were other like bad [ __ ] that happened
to him like in the course of it me like
uh something yeah some of these kind of
kind of pushed him toward - and then
some of these kind of mysterious shifty
characters in the beginning of the
movies that you think they might be bad
guys later on you find out you go oh
okay now it starts to make sense so you
know I mean it it's not all spelled out
for you you know and this in the same
way to say like Shazam is know the tone
is very different the tone is very like
Batman Begins yeah I would say like but
not not a high-budget
and it didn't need it no it didn't need
it but I'd like to see it again I'd like
to see it up like this is equal yeah
yeah you know if this was a successful
which I don't see why it wouldn't be I
don't know if the marketing really fit
this is this should have been marketed
as a superhero I mean you should have
spent a little more money on it but I
don't know it feels like a DC movie kind
of yeah but like I said that mostly like
I said if you like did you like the
Punisher yeah that's true almost kind of
like I'm sure almost kind of like
Netflix like a Netflix Punisher yeah
that was that that was the strongest buy
about yeah I guess you could say so yeah
yeah but I'm interested in seeing more
yeah it's a good movie
[Music]
you
all right we just got done seeing one
called the hustle that was pretty good
we're all side here in the parking lot
drinking didn't know about that huh
haven't in between movies really have a
second picnic yeah we bring a cooler
with like sandwiches and yes coffee
Kukulcan yeah so we're gonna watch
Tolkien next I'm gonna be loaded for
this one anyway
we saw one everybody hustle yeah we saw
the hustle it was good I was laughing
too the whole thing that's about some
female con man they're called women what
is that con artists yeah yeah Tom
biogenic town yeah don't know I feel
like now if I recall correctly
cuz like I said anybody that watches the
show knows that I don't really really
reviews or anything like that before the
movies usually we see the trailers but
that's about it
if I recall correctly I think this movie
might be a loose reboot of a dirty
rotten scoundrels if anybody remembers
that maybe I think he came out in the
late eighties trying to say 87 89
I feel like Steve Martin and maybe
Michael Caine I saw it a long time ago
but this is essentially this a similar
story where it's Anne Hathaway she plays
like a like a really accomplished con
woman and rebel Wilson is also a con
woman and trashy one yeah and she's like
a trashy one yeah but they kind of meet
up and then Anne Hathaway kind of
teaches or some tricks but really she
just wants her to go away because they
really don't get along and there's like
a competition and all this others like I
don't want to ruin it but yeah you know
if you've seen dirty rotten scoundrels
this is very very similar in tone
you said it almost reminded you'd like
the settings and stuff are kind of like
a James Bond film is very glamorous yeah
they're on this [ __ ] European Island
you know they named it I don't know if
it's a real go monster
yeah but you know that's a real place or
not but it's just like a place where
just the rich people hang out yeah and
they're down there yeah they're down
there [ __ ] just abusing them and
taking all their money in lines and they
all you know she she lives in the
[ __ ] palaces [ __ ] beautiful
[ __ ] house and she's got other con
people [ __ ] working for her and
everything you know impersonating cops
and is this pretty cool as almost kinda
like a kind of had like that you know
that old-school James Bond tone you know
like you know the Roger Moore era
you know it's just kind of funny you
know it was just kind of fun you know
and it's just all these little glamorous
places that they were at and they were
[ __ ] each other over everything it
was funny like I said I laughed I
laughed yeah yeah yeah this was a very
fun movie and like I said it was very it
stayed very true to the tone of dirty
rotten scoundrels so it's not like it's
weird because it didn't have like a
wacky score it didn't have anything like
that it was very um it was very
throwback I thought like the way it was
edited the way it was shot and stuff
which I really liked about it and also I
have to say we we also saw rebel Wilson
and isn't it romantic and I also liked
her in that she's very funny and I like
that she's kind of just willing to do
whatever I mean like the physical comedy
like she you know she dresses up like is
it disgusting like I don't know what
that like some kind of peasant or
something right okay so with like these
gross teeth and all this other kind of
stuff so she will just do anything to
get a laugh and I think it's like really
works well and interestingly like her
and Anne Hathaway play really well off
each other like especially after they
get into the big competition you know
who's gonna be the best con artist or
whatever and you know they're trying to
like undermine each other and stuff like
that and there's like a really good
chemistry between the two of them it's
just a good movie just yet movies I
thought it was like super fun it's a
good feel good movie it's not anything
really really complicated they didn't do
anything
like new and inventive they just stuck
with the formulas that [ __ ] work
yeah this [ __ ] that actually works so
and like I said if you like dirty rotten
scoundrels back in the day I don't see
any reason why you wouldn't like this
one it's the same plot but there's like
different you know different stuff
happens in it if I recall her excitement
and her perfectly good comedy I was just
laughing with whole thing's a lot better
than that other was that one called the
long shot long shot long shot [ __ ]
suck a lot better than that long shot I
like this was actually yeah
okay just got done seeing tolking which
was a period piece and uh you know about
the life of Tolkien him growing up as a
as a as an orphan and Oxford nas buddies
and then how you know they go marching
off the War World War one and he comes
back and you know actually before he
left he fell in love with a girl he
ended up marrying her when he get back
and and then it goes into the 33 right
before he wrote The Hobbit good movie
man look it look really it was a really
good looking period piece I mean it was
a beautiful idea now you got to be a
Tolkien fan and you better be you know
ready for Kabul slow burn it's kind of
slow in certain points you know it's
kind of really covering him and his
friends in detail you know it's good
yeah a lot of it centers around like his
child in his college years like they
don't really go much into like later on
it goes up to World War one and then
there's like a little bit in the third
act like about later on like before you
were at The Hobbit but not much it's
mostly like focus yeah it's good movie
it's not an action movies not a
feel-good movie or anything like that I
mean bad should happen to him in World
War two but even World War one but you
know he made it you know he made it
through lost some buddies and [ __ ] you
know but yeah he's a good movie you just
got to be in the mood for it you know
you got to be into the into Hobbit and
Lord of the Rings and be interested in
this guy if you're not interested in
this guy you never liked it yeah well I
mean I really really like this Mineola
and like nicholas hoult was like really
really good on this yeah i'm welcome
anyway he's like he's such a great actor
we first up he was not
and you know at max fury road and I
think he's in the x-men movies too yeah
but yeah I always liked him as an actor
so he's like he doesn't amazing job in
this and I especially liked like all the
scenes of world war one and it kind of
like intercut with his fantasy show
wearing it up all the word got the idea
we got this really cool like it wasn't
like overdone but it was like really
really nice the way there there was one
thing do you know if this movie kind of
reminded me of a little bit Dead Poets
Society yeah thank you ladies in school
Mamie but it had a little bit of that
vibe to it was a little a lot more
serious than that
I think did pose science more humor to
it but it didn't really have a lot of
humor it did in the beginning but yeah I
mean if you're into Lord of the Rings
and if you're like interested in Jer or
Tolkien it's person who's definitely see
this because yeah yeah it's really
really good yeah if you're not into it
then you're not really gonna resonate
yeah it's kind of the thing where cuz
like I said it's very slow it's very you
know it's we were very lyrical yeah you
know yeah I get a thumbs up for what it
is for what it was
you